on les bouge ça génial ça va alourdir en
ardoise quoi voilà tout donc interview
mensonge jacques mellick est ce que vous
êtes toujours de droite
bien entendu c'est formidable bon bien
alors il ya un haute mer qu'à quai des
soucis en ce moment c'est tiberi est ce
que vous allez l'aider à c'est évident
ouais vous l'aimez beaucoup tiberi h au
nord un type honnête a profondément
c'est pas le genre à faire des pauses
électeurs et les trucs comme ça on garde
regardez le couple ouais un rapport et
xavière mais pressage à 400 milles est
ce que vous trouvez pas demain jacques
mellick convoi pu sarkozy si souvent
tabou est extraordinaire c'est nous sont
éprouvants oui je me sens très proche de
lui sur ses sur ses idées et il est
sympathique mais déjà trompé votre femme
vous avez déjà trouvé peut-être que
c'est quand vous faites un tableau de
mensonges que vous dites maintenant dix
mois sans jambes lisses ml c'est déjà
assez compliqué est ce que c'est vrai ce
qu'on raconte que vous êtes un des plus
gros clients des boîtes échangistes du
nord pas de calais hélas je dois le
reconnaître
ouais pourquoi vous étiez là c'est
agréable quand même temps il paraît vous
y prenez beaucoup de plaisir à beaucoup
je prends du plaisir comme le dit elvia
et ses vacances tout seul en thaïlande
cet été ça s'est bien passé
voilà j'étais très bien ophélie winter
j'étais avec ophélie winter en thaïlande
a dit non à phuket généraux donc c'est
vrai
alors jacques mellick est ce que c'est
vrai que vous avez arrêté de fumer des
cigares depuis le pic de l'air pur
maintenant parce que les cigarettes ça
donne le cancer
10-15 pétards par jour non oui au moins
et pour relancer l'agriculture dans le
pas de calais vous avez cultiver le
chambre ça c'est faisons une expérience
ouais vous comment s'est absenté sur
quelques hectares sur quelques hectares
très bien et ça fera du boulot à la
place de testut sera fermée alors
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
menti durant cette interview mensonges
bien entendu